just as a headline here you're trying to
fix global warming by bringing woolly
mammoths back to life amongst a number
of other extinct
creatures right well I I don't think
that one company can fix global warming
I I think that we are at the you know
brink of a major biodiversity crisis
which will lead to ecosystem collapse
and uh restoring ecosystems like the
Arctic tundra is something that you know
we're very focused on so I hope that we
are one of many people working on uh
biodiversity loss and combating climate
change but uh I think it's maybe a
little bold to say that we're we are
solving it ourselves I understand okay
so somebody comes up to you at a
cocktail party and says what do you do
what is your answer for your day-to-day
work so my my general answer is I say
I'm in technology if they dive deeper
I'm like well I'm in biotechnology if
they dive deeper I tell them that we're
working to bring back extinct species
and preserve all life on Earth and then
it and then it kind of unravels from
there right
okay talk talk to me about de Extinction
then like what what even is that yeah so
de Extinction is uh not necess not
necessarily A New Concept other
everything from books and movies and and
some other movements uh through in the
world have talked about the concept of
De Extinction and the way we view de
Extinction is the de Extinction of core
genes to build proxy species for uh
genetics that have been lost uh to time
whether that was you know uh due to
solely you know climate change events or
towards or due to the fact of man's uh
implications right and so uh
fundamentally we are de extincting the
core genes that make all of these
species that unique species and so
recently I was on a podcast where
someone wanted to uh debate semantics
over the do and and they're like but
sure dodo is just going to be a silly
looking pigeon and I hated to inform
them that a Dodo was a silly looking
pigeon Doos were pigeons and so uh the
things that made it a different
flightless pigeon were the genes that
were de extincting and so it definitely
brings out you know different uh groups
have different perspectives on on the
work that we're doing but but
fundamentally we're bringing back these
lost species uh to to increase
biodiversity and then we're using all
those Technologies for conservation
which is pretty cool okay nuts and
bolts how the do you bring a dead
animal back to life so you can't you
can't clone a a a a a dead animal uh you
don't have living cells so what you have
to do is you have to look for its
closest living relative so in the case
of the mammoth that's the Asian elephant
mammoths are actually closer related to
Asian elephants than Asian elephants are
to African elephants which is like like
that blew my mind when I learned that
because I I I was also the first to the
extinction when I was working on this
and what was interesting is you actually
have to then go look at the DNA
sequences and so we actually had to
assemble 54 Mammoth genomes to build out
kind of a reference genome that we can
do all the comparative genomics to that
of the Asian elephant and they're about
99.6% the same genetically and so then
and then in that difference of0 4% so a
lot of genes we then started to isolate
what are the genes that really made a
mammoth of Mammoth you know the D
cranium the curve Tusk The Shaggy coat
these extra fat layer how they produce
oxygen and sub freezing temperatures and
so we we did have to spend a lot of time
doing computational analysis to really
understand that and then we take and
engineer those genes into that of an
Asian elephant cell then we go through
the cloning process kind of like what
they did with Dolly the sheep back in
the 90s only it's way more efficient now
and it uses is like lasers and stuff
like that versus back in the 90s they
were kind of just jamming stuff together
which is weird but it kind of worked
then now actually really works because
it's way more precise uh and then you
and then you actually implant that
embryo into the closest living relative
being the Asian elephant uh from a
surrogacy perspective where do you get
the genomics of a animal that's not when
did they when was the last wly Mammoth
alive so so the last ones actually were
about 3,500 uh uh BC so they were up in
Wrangle Island so they've been extinct
for for quite some time uh ironically
though during the the building of the
pyramids the last mammoths were still
alive so it's kind of kind of weird it
kind of blows people Minds a lot of
people think that that mammoths
um were like around the time of the
dinosaurs and so they're like that's 65
million years old it's not and a lot of
the DNA comes from the permafrost
because animals will die up there uh
they will instantly start to freeze uh
layers ofnow snow and ice layers of snow
and ice and so there's tons of preserved
species up in the permafrost and so you
know over the last 15 years there's been
incredible researchers like George churs
and loua Doan and bapiro and in teams
that we work these teams that we work
with that have actually gone on
expeditions to the permafrost to extract
ancient DNA so it's a little bit of
Science Fiction and Jurassic Parky it's
a little bit of Indiana Jones it's it's
really interesting how it kind of all
comes together uh in De Extinction
science today so you have is it entire
animals or is it is it bones of animal
what's preserved because you know lots
of can get preserved in in Frost
right yeah lots of can be preserved
in Frost um but but it depends so in the
case of the uh dodo bird some of the
some of it is just in uh some of the DNA
is actually just taken from the bone or
the inner beak that they've actually
drilled into in the case the thus scene
you know which went extinct only in
1936 uh Hunters actually preserved one
of the pups that they killed in uh in
alcohol uh that ended up being in a
museum and so that was really well
preserved in the case of the permafrost
with Mammoth you know sometimes you get
actual flesh sometimes you get actual
you know uh hairs sometimes you get
actual meat uh it's very old and very
disgusting it's got lots of bacteria so
I wouldn't recommend eating it some
people have which is crazy uh but a
great place to get ancient DNA is you
mentioned it is teeth so some teeth do a
great job of preserving it and there's
an inner ear bone called The petris Bone
where you actually get great DNA from uh
species that are 10,000 years or older
what do you mean when you say great DNA
is this a a an area where it's but it's
not it's not degraded over time there's
a high density of it it's there's a high
density of it there's massive there's
there is you know things like heat and
sun and radiation are all very very bad
for DNA and so DNA starts to degrade the
minutes outside of your body so it is
definitely degraded DNA but you can get
more and more of it if it's in these
well preserved spots like teeth like the
Petra bone or really well Frozen and we
and we've gotten all of it over over the
times and we're actually doing a project
right now with the University of Alaska
um and and this group uh this this
program that we put together called adop
a mammoth where we're actually taking
teeth samples we're giving them from the
from universities uh from the museums in
Alaska giving them and loaning them to
uh school kids showing them how you
extract ancient DNA and we're doing a
whole both radiocarbon dating and
population genomic study in sequencing
all of these Alaskan mammoths so it's a
way to bring kids into it bring it's a
way to promote education you know
because dtin is pretty cool
right um but then also it's it's an
incredible way for us to get tons of dat
data that we can use to understand
populations of American mammoths because
a lot of the mammoths that we have are
actually from Siberia so they're Russian
mammoths oh interesting and you
mentioned 53 uh different uh samples
that was taken and all of those are
combined presumably the goal here is if
we have uh you know like 98% degradation
of the genome but we get tons of them
like 50 of them we can build that up
over time and Hope we get somewhere
close to actually seeing a full sequence
you'll never get to fully 100% I mean
you just won't right and so some of this
stuff happens in the regulatory regions
some this happens in the non-regulatory
regions so you don't even really need as
as much as as you may think uh there's
an area that I I learned about when we
started working on this about kind of
DNA coverage and the number of reads
that the system does because even these
sequencers aren't perfect right so
they're they're basically giving you a
probabilist a probability score of what
what that letter is on in terms of the
the individual nucleotides in the in the
in the DNA sequence and so what's
interesting is the more DNA you get then
the the more reads you can do the higher
probability right because if you can go
to 20 to 50x coverage that means that
they've gone through the whole genome 20
to 50 times so that means that that
there's a higher likelihood they're
going to be correct the machines to be
correct in telling you what that
specific letter is and so anytime you
get 25
X up sometimes as low as you know teens
up you typically get enough The genome
that you can get pretty precise okay so
let's say that you now have compared the
African elephant Asian as Asian elephant
you've compared the Asian elephants to
these 53 AI enhanced sequenced
differences there's this 4% or 6% which
is the difference we've got this yeah
now what now like what do you would you
would you you going to 3D print a
mammoth like what are we doing here just
and just guess no you actually do
molecular and functional assays and
tests to understand what did those genes
do and what's interesting from both a
convergent evolution and a general
Evolution perspective you can start to
see in different species how certain
hair for example grows so we we know
this about Mammoth which is really
interesting I always thought that mam
just had long hair right they actually
have five different types of hair uh and
so different genes and different
pathways do that and so one of the
things that we're doing with with
colossal which we find interesting is
we're not only looking at what were the
genes in in the single Gene and and
additional genes that work together to
produce that phenotype or physical
attribute of that species but we're ALS
we have an entire uh genotype to
phenotype team our GTP team that looks
and leverages Ai and some of these Great
Tech neur neurot Technologies to
actually under try to understand how do
things like size how do things like hair
how does that work cross million species
right even with different genes like
what are the different stages of
development so we're doing a lot of work
in in kind of General genotype to
phenotype around big core things like
you know everything from size to cranial
facial shapes uh you know to Fat
patterns to to patterns of the actual
kind of fur and then as well as you know
looking at things like like hair and fur
length and and different regular regions
like that so it's really interesting
because for from for our perspective
because we're working on multiple
species we have our individual teams
that's trying to solve the individual uh
challenge of each species and then we've
got this cross functional team that's
trying to look for trends that can be
applied to other mammals right and that
can be really helpful for like you know
drop resistant cattle in in other
species okay moving forward how do we
make a
mammoth yeah so um the the way you do it
is you go through that computational
analysis first you get the DNA then you
symble the DNA then you actually uh do
that computational an Anis and once you
have your targeted Gene list you then go
through the actual process of editing
Asian elephant cells right because
they're the closest living so we did you
mentioned African elephants we did a uh
work with the vertebrae Genome Project
to do a full reference Genome of the
African elephant more for conservation
than really for our project we did find
some interesting differences between
mammoths Asian elephants and African
elephants that that uh we are starting
to explore um but once you do that you
go through the process of understanding
what that Gene list is you then start
making edits and you start with looking
for the edits that you think are going
to be the highest impact you then do a
bunch of tests to make sure that those
edits actually took uh and then once you
get to a point that you feel like you've
got a cell with the edits that you feel
comfortable with you do sequencing just
like we did at the beginning on those
cells to make sure that the edits are
there and they didn't create what's
called of Target effects meaning things
that you didn't mean to break in the
genome uh and so once you feel like
you're comfortable there you then go
into user process process called sematic
cell nuclear transfer or cloning and
that's where we take the nucleus of a
sematic cell and we put it into that of
a germ cell or what's a sematic cell for
the people that don't know so so so
sematic cells are basically all the
cells in your body that are or in an
animal's body that are not sperm andex
so those are those are like skin cells
different types of tissue cells so we
take the nucleus or that brain out of a
sematic cell and we put it into that of
a germ cell or an egg cell and then
effectively you've got you know the
basis of an embryo
you then use a process of slight
electrification and and some some other
media and then it starts to divide and
once you get to the right stage of of
division you then implant that into a a
surrogate in the case of the woolly
mammoth that's the Asian elephant um so
so that's how it works in mammals how it
works uh in in Birds is is is slightly
uh different um it it it's a little bit
different of a process but it's a much
easier gestation process so if that's
interesting for Doos I could talk about
that or yeah yeah I want to know how I I
want to know how a bird so birds are
even like what's interesting to me about
birds is the gestational side because
we're not going through uh the sematic
nuclear transfer or that cloning
stepping Birds uh birds are harder on
the front end but they're so much easier
currently on the back end right because
we don't have to work we don't have to
go work on the cacy side you don't have
to do the embryo transfer you don't have
to do uh the nucleus transfer so what's
great about birds is you you while we
can't clone Birds currently in the world
meaning that we can't find the the uh
nucleus at the right time of development
to move it so you can't clone Birds yet
maybe one day you can there's debate on
whether it's possible but you know
everything was impossible till it's not
right and so um but what's interesting
is what we are doing is is we're
actually using chickens as our host and
so this blew my mind kind of like how
close fam and Asian elephants were when
you take you can cultivate what's called
primordial germ cells so the precursors
to egg and sperm right and then you edit
those you can then use that and build a
Ed an edited chicken with these edited
primordial germ cells so this is where
it gets crazy uh I mean at least for me
being in the extinction um you can then
have edited primordial germ cells
chicken a and edited primonial germ cell
chicken be those chickens can fall in
love and depending on your World Views
they get married or whatever and then
they have a baby and they have an egg
when that egg hatches it is based on
what you put into the primordial germ
cells so they done this and created
transgenic transgenic Ducks where they
they put edited duck cells in pgc's Prim
sa in a chicken one they've done it in
chicken two uh those chickens grow up
those chickens fall in love they get
married whatever they have they have a
baby uh an egg the egg hatches and it's
a duck and so what's amazing is is that
chickens uh will actually be the
surrogates for our first dodos which as
we talked about briefly early our
pigeons so
[Music]
um it's an interesting it's an
interesting world and and now we're even
exploring I don't know if it's possible
but I'm having to share with you we are
exploring bird cloning right because we
were told this is how you have to do it
using these uh using these types of
primordial germ cells so that was the
process that we followed uh but then you
know we were like but why doesn't bird
cloning work and we got lots of feedback
they're like huh maybe we'll try that so
we are working on bird cloning not sure
if it's going to work uh but if not
we'll go down this uh PGC route that
seems uh pretty plausible okay so
getting back to the mammoth there's an
unclosed there's an unclosed Loop about
that one we have this Asian elephant
this unsuspecting mother Asian elephant
who is is going to give birth to what
What will what will ultimately come out
of this elephant yeah so so it's a great
question uh it will it will be our kind
of Mammoth 1.0 right so we take it's an
Asian elephant that has been edited so I
come from software so I think of things
like software so our 1.0 will produce
all the core phenotypes that we know and
love in a woolly Bama so we're de
extincting all the core hair jees the
cranial facial shape that D Cranium uh
the tus uh morphology in terms of the
the curv tus uh as well as like shorter
Tails smaller ears and then there's some
stuff that's kind of under the hood like
how you know how the the uh mammoths are
more cold tolerant with certain fat
layers with the ability for uh their
nerve endings not to fry at sub freezing
temperatures the ability to produce
hemoglobin and oxygen you know laser
eyes yeah yeah there are no laser eyes
but that's that's a that's a h we got
asked if we could make a thilosene with
laser eyes um so we get a lot of
interesting requests believe it or
not right so I is it accurate to say
that it's a mammoth or is it accurate to
say that it's an entirely new species
it's it's really not so so the iucn in
the species survival commission which
kind of like the UN species which is
amazing we work very closely with them
defines a new species as something that
gave rise in nature so it's not really a
new species uh at least how it's how
it's but it's also not a mammoth right
because I mean it has all the core and
so so this this goes into I I mentioned
this earlier right you know whether you
think a a Dodo is a silly looking pigeon
or a mammoth is is an elephant a mammoth
was an elephant like that's just what
they were they're packs that that's what
they were and so I don't know like my
dogs are muts right and I would argue
that most species are hybrids and that's
hybridization gives rise to newer
species right and so you know if some
people aren't happy unless we clone
a 100% of a mammoth then then I would
argue that you know it's a cold adjusted
uh genetically modified elephant with
extinct mammoth alals from a series of
biodiversity gaps of you know three to
five or 10,000 years right so so much
less sexy as a name yeah I mean if
that's what you want to call it that's
what you want to call it but I mean for
you and me or at least for me when I see
it and well if we are successful you
know it has all the core phenotypes if
it's cold adapted if we've de extincted
the core genes that made a mammoth a
mammoth then then to me that's a mammoth
right you know our our our goal is not
to create uh there's a lot of
infrastructure uh in the genome that's
just it doesn't produce uh any real
effects so um we could add thousands of
thou upon thousands of of edits to our
our Mammoth that don't have any you know
true meaningful effect but from a purist
perspective you someone could say oh
that's closer to a
mammoth yeah okay you know that that's
at least how we view it functionally
it's a mammoth right so it's a
functional Mammoth it's a MTH looks like
Mammoth it drives like a mammoth
yeah right at least that's that's how we
how we think about it we there is a
small percentage of folks that disagree
with this but you know you mean the MTH
purists out there if the Mammoth purist
want to go a step further they can and
and and we and we welcome them
too okay uh what about like gation and
stuff because I I there's got to be
differences and and and into utro
there's there's definitely
intro um the uh uh so it's
about 22 months of gestation so it's a
very long gestational cycle right uh
which you know I come I I try to think
of things from a systems design
perspective right and so for me that's
one of the reasons why I love the
thilosene so if I can dumb down the
process what's what's the thyine
Tasmanian Tiger it's a it's a large car
it the largest carnivorous
marsupial wow yeah it's all it kind of
looks like a wolf from a it's not
genetically related to a wolf but but
from a convergent evolution perspective
meaning that in the isolated population
it kind of looks like a wolf like if you
look at a Pine and a wolf skull I'd say
99 out of 100 times people would say oh
the same there's only one small
difference uh in the inside uh but
what's really interesting is that
through conversion Evolution almost
looks like a wolf but but going back to
your question uh from a gational
perspective you've got 22 months with
the mammoth with the thilosene you have
13 and a half days now so that that's
the end of the process the beginning of
the process is computational biology
right like assembling the reference
genome with the mammoth we had 54 MMO
genomes you have to do a lot of work to
your point it's very degraded you have
to do so much work on it on the thylo
scene we got over a 92% complete read on
the first read right so that's easier
but then in the middle on the editing
lots of more edits that are required in
the thine than in the mammoth so it's
it's like hard easier hard uh and then
this one was easy harder easy so what's
interesting from a systems perspective
looking at this is you can look at the
entire kind of like system in mamillion
D Extinction and build a system that
kind of has to work for both and so
that's where we're spending a lot of
time I will say that it is a lot easier
to just say the the thoene in the M yeah
I guess that one Asian elephant is
looked at very very carefully for 22
months like do not let it out of your
sight if it goes
missing you you are in trouble all right
so what um what about what could go
wrong during this this process are there
any well any any thing I mean there's a
I mean anytime you're doing something
that's hard from a science perspective
things could go wrong right like you you
could not fully get all of the right
edits made you could not only that you I
mean we we can test for you know whether
we made them right but do all of the
edits produce the phenotypes or or core
phys physical attributes that we're
looking for right um how does the
sematic cell transfer process work in
elephant versus Bine versus pig versus
dog versus
M right and so there's still nuances to
that right and then gestationally you
know the the thing that's really
interesting is that I don't think
there's been an a this whole concept of
xenot transfer right of like or xenot
transplantation of taking something from
one species to another you know sounds
like crazy but we see it all the time
people get
xenotransplantation pieces of pigs in
their hearts and go live normal lives
right we also see that that um you know
uh we also see that that species like a
mammoth which is closely related to an
Asian elephant uh than it is to a than
an Asian elephant is to an African
elephant African elephants and Asian
elephants can actually interpre and
produce FAL Offspring and so these are
two genetically distant species that are
further apart than these two and
remember to your point earlier we're not
making exactly this we're making
somewhere in between right so we're even
closer to an Nation outfit so we believe
there's a high degree of confidence
uh in that inner species uh uh transfer
and in that in that surrogacy um but
people ask me all the time will the
mammoth be the first species due to the
22mon gestation I I I think it's highly
likely there would be another species oh
it's gonna get pipped at the it's gonna
start off on the race first and it's
going to end up coming in last it's got
22 months of gation I mean that's just
that's that's hard to you know time to
grow a mammoth yeah there there people
there's other species that could do a
Victory lap before
yeah you've got an entire Army of those
things that look like wolves uh all
right what else actually here's a
question so it seems to me with my
extensive knowledge of how genomic
sequencing works that the main limiting
factor is the quality of the DNA that
you can get from whatever the sample is
of the animal is that right I think that
that's overcome I I don't think that's
that's the the limiting thing I think
that that the I'll get to limiting I
think that what you just said is
overcome with more samples right and so
we've got incredible Partners like loua
dollan in Stockholm it's you know
lalin's arguably one of the most
knowledgeable people in the world of the
genes that make a mammoth of Mammoth and
he's constantly just finding and
sequencing more man so I think that we
can probabilistically get through what
you just suggested um I think that the
biggest issue and I think they're
different for species but you know it's
just editing right what's what's amazing
is that we have a lot of incredible
editing Technologies people kind of just
Clump all genium editing as one thing
but there's a lot of different
Technologies there's editing individual
letters in kind of that Twisted ladder
right each one of those rungs you can
edit individual ones you can knock out
pieces of it uh you can edit multiple
things at the same time all over the
genome that's called Multiplex editing
that's where we are spending a lot of
time and we're trying to be the most
Innovative company in the world being
able to edit a lot of the parts of the
genome at one time so you don't have to
be so precise you can edit that same
level of precision all over and we've
had you know over 90% uh efficacy
already proven internally which is
amazing uh for our edits and we're
trying to stack those and then you come
to to DNA synthesis where it's like to
your if you can get to your point
earlier if you can get that that that
right amount of you know letters in the
right order and you have high degree of
con uh of confidence in it you could
synthesize a big piece of that and then
just swap it in so in areas where
there's lots of edits instead of doing
lots of edits you know either using kind
of some of these uh individual editing
tools or even editing Multiplex or even
synthesizing pieces full pieces of DNA
and swapping it in because that may have
you know 20 different edits that we
didn't have to make because we really
only had to synthesize it and then swap
in one so so I think that that depending
on how far we want to push editing I
think that in the the rate at which
editing um the rate at which Ed in
Technologies progress will probably be
the limiting factor not on our success
but on the number of edits that can be
made when it comes to other animals if
we were to try and get more exotic the I
mean the Jurassic Park memes write
themselves with this yeah we we've we've
heard that before yeah it doesn't
surprise me um with those what's the
limiting factor there why is it the case
that you maybe you can but why is it the
why is it the case that you can't do
something which is a little bit more
exotic um well I mean I would argue that
no one to my knowledge has seen a
mammoth so it's pretty exotic more
exotic you know older older let's call
not call it more exotic I'm not going to
make a value judgment on your Mammoth
older yeah so um I mean cyas is pretty
exotic um macius is very exotic Place
beautiful with Doos um so uh you know
right limiting you know you can't you
know Harvest DNA bone you know Kenneth
laara who's incredible he's one of the
top paleontologists in the world he he
discovered dread natis he's also one of
the most interesting people in the world
uh the largest dinosaur ever tradus uh
he's actually been able to demineralize
Bones dinosaur bones and get pieces
amino acids right but amino acids and
even some proteins and some collagens
but that does not that's not a big chunk
of DNA right so uh we get the Amber
question we get the dino DNA question so
I guess there is technically dinosaur
collagen and
dinosaur uh amino acids and maybe some
proteins here and there but that is so
so the pieces of confetti you're now
making pieces of confetti of pieces of
DNA confetti of confetti to try to so a
dinosaur it does not maketh it it it
does not and so so right now we can go
back about a million years uh I haven't
seen the latest in terms of what what's
been sequenced but I know we've been
able to sequence 700,000 to to a million
years and get viable DNA but at some
point you know and so so that there's a
lot of exotic stuff between than in now
um uh also you know uh cold uh dry
environments are great for DNA um you
know hot a lot of people love to talk
about the lraa tarpits we get a lot of
questions about the lia tarpits and uh
you know hot acid filled places are not
great for DNA um there's been some
really cool animals that have gone
extinct in warm wet and climates that
you know aren't great for DNA uh so you
can't make those we a big fan favorite
is a giant sloth people would there
there used to be a giant sloth that was
the size of a tree a giant ground sloth
that would literally and there's like
some I've read some stories about how
they loved avocados and how they
propagated avocados I don't know if
there's any truth to that but it's one
of the recent things I've read about um
so so there are lots of kind of uh
different species that you know are
interesting I think that a lot of the
pine species late Pine species make a
lot of sense because there is great
preser or there is a as great as
preservation as you could probably get
uh because you know early early humans
weren't sticking them in you
know sub freezing temperature freezers
at the time right okay what else from
the last million years if you were to
have a a hit list a top of the pops
aside from your Mammoth and your dodo
what else what else is in there for I
would like to bring this back well I
mean I think you have to have a reason
you know why um one of no no Ben this is
we are completely liberated from
resources ethics or a service of
humanity what do you want to bring back
I think it's hard to to fully liberate
ourselves from service of humanity or or
ethics there there's a couple species
that I find very interesting
um I think the great a is really
interesting it was like the American
penguin it's super cool I think that it
served a purpose um I think that there's
a whale siiz uh manatee or dong called
uh the Stellar sea Cal we we can't bring
it back we actually have DNA for it but
there's nothing to just say it it's just
too big unless we get exure exor
development devices to work uh which
which we do have a 17 person team
working on um uh you know fan favorite
is uh saber-tooth cat uh which there
were there were there were several but
there were two that were um pretty
prominant one being home ethereum and
one being Smilodon Smilodon had the
bigger Tusk that you know the big
canines that we think of um so I I think
all of those are pretty interesting
candidates uh you know I don't we can't
do the Stellar SE Cal but I think that'd
be incredible to see like a you know
blue whale size you know Manatee like
you'd be likey and apparently they were
like incredibly helpful to the Kel
Forest of the Pacific Northwest and so
um they they were also big carbon sinks
like like elephants so um those are all
really cool uh species we're not working
on any of them currently all right so
what's aside from aside from the mammoth
the mammoth being a very useful one and
I want to get on to why it's
particularly useful and aside from these
other ones that are like the sexy ones
um what else would you don't think a
mammoth is sexy I think a mammoth is
pretty sexy I'm not I'm not a hairy hair
hair that much hair is too much for me
um what else is particularly useful from
the last 1 million years like I said we
have these very specific use cases for
certain animals so I'll hit the use
cases of of of the non the the two non
mouth species and then and then kind of
I guess parly than other species but so
spefic specifically with the doto
bringing back the doto doesn't like fix
the ecosystem of marians but bringing
back the dodo which is a symbol of of of
man caused uh Extinction will force us
and the maian government who we're
working very closely with on uh removing
the invasive species that actually led
to the Doo's Extinction so a lot of
people love to just say that Doos were
dumb and uh people just ate them uh you
know know there's actually not as much
data suggesting that as that because
they were a ground dwelling species of
flightless bird and they laid their eggs
on the ground one time a year long
longer gestation Cycles uh when you
bring in you know invasive species like
pigs and rats and other things they eat
the stuff that's on the ground because
they can't clb trees right for the most
part and so um and so the process of
bringing back the dodo in collaboration
with you know local people and
governments indigenous people groups and
whatnot uh we will if we do want to
successfully re them in Marias uh and
then the neighboring Islands then we
actually have to do a process of
ecosystem restoration so it's forcing us
to undo some of the sins of the past of
in introducing these invasive species
right so so the a lot of times people
ask us about the dodo it doesn't really
solve a pure ecological impact besides
forcing us to undo that which also could
help other species that are native to to
to those islands um in the case of the
thilosene or Tasmanian tiger some people
also call it Tasmanian wolf but more
commonly Tasmanian tiger um you know it
was the largest apex predator in
Tasmania and Lowa Australia and what
what people don't realize is people just
think oh creditors Easy Life top of the
food chain it's like no those are
actually the big herbivores those have
easier lives you know because they're
just eating grass there's a lot of
energy expenditure that happens in
carnivores to go make a kill right and
so if you're a carnivore and your J and
and you're if you're an animal carnivore
I should say and you're out in the field
and you have to go actually like make a
kill versus just get it from your local
whole whole foods and you actually have
to go do the work you're GNA be very
strategic you're going to expend that
ener that that energy expenditure very
wisely you're going to look for either
the small old weak or sick animals to to
pick them off and so what people don't
realize is that that a lot of these
carnivores had tremendous help in in in
in in kind of securing the balance of
the ecosystem not just because they're
thinning herds because they're also
eating a lot of the stuff that that you
know in killing off the weak the young
or the sick and so one of the animals
that that Tasmanian tigers probably
prayed on was the Tasmanian devil was
smaller in the in in in the stack and
now due to this whole facial tumor
disease and they don't have any natural
Predators anymore they are actually
spreading this terrible facial tumor uh
cancer to each other when they eat I
I've been with Tasmanian devils in the
wild and um it's h it's very interesting
they're very aggressive and um and so
when they're doing that they're fighting
each other clawing each other and
whatnot and they they actually get
pretty beat up during that kind of
feeding F frenzy process and they
actually pass that disease well if D
thingss were around or or a larger um
animal that Frayed on them they would
most likely thin out a lot of those uh
animals that can't walk very well or see
very well due to the facial T diseas
right so then there's less that can
actually produce that so that whole
effect is called Tropic downgrading when
you when you uh have a predator that
actually can remove uh that from the
wild and and that helps balance the
ecosystem right and so you know uh Dr
Andrew Pas who's one of our partners on
the thyine Rew Wilding restoration or
Rew Wilding project has been very uh
adamant on on uh their demise has led to
the potential demise of the Devils which
is which is terrible um so so those are
those are the non- mammoth species
impact okay so why why the ma like the
mammoth is kind of a it holds a
particularly good cultural position the
dodo I really like that thing about the
dodo that it's not about what it does
functionally but what it does
symbolically that look guys we we went
through all of this effort to bring this
thing back because of how Topsy turby
the ecology of this particular location
when you got to fix this I I think
that's it's just a really really smart
way of playing with human psychology the
mammoth also kind of is symbolic in some
regards I I don't know if we actually do
know why it went extinct was it hunted
to Extinction was it whatever whatever
yeah there's a lot of different depends
on who you ask right like there's there
are scientific peer reviewed papers that
say early man uh uh hunted them to
Extinction there's other papers that
show in research that shows that you
know it was it was uh climate and in the
evolving climate that pushed them
further north and then there's genetic
bottleneck and rangle Island the the
last M died of of uh inbreeding um but
most likely what most people don't
realize and so I think there I think the
answer is somewhere in between um
because I think there's data I mean we
have you know proof of early man hunting
mammoths we we have you know there's
there's spear marks and stuff like that
in some mammoths uh there's actually
mammoth tools that have been used right
and so so I do think that that were're
that were designed and built at that
time I think more than likely you know
with with elephants specifically you
have 22 months gestation then you have
about six years to get to the point that
they are truly adult elephants elephants
and then there's about a 12 to 13e
sexual maturity process so if you want
to kill elephants you actually don't
have to eradicate elephants you don't
have to eradicate all of them you just
have to eradicate enough of them because
of that cycle you know uh you know
whether it's the environment or Predator
someone will thin them off over time to
to get to Extinction re from A
reproduction perspective and from a
fertility perspective elephants
generally are a fragile creature long
gestation long time as a relatively
useless unprotected infant still
relatively useless sexually finally we
can do it you know it's just there's a
lot of opportunity to be dead in that
before you get to the point to to to
pass on your jeans one thing about
elephants though and and we are we are
working on this as it relates to Mammoth
the extinction we're not we're not
looking at it from a cancer perspective
but one of the things that's interesting
about elephants and I believe also blue
whales is they have an overexpression of
of of this protein called
p53 you you and I and mice we have about
one expression of it they have seven and
what's interesting is if you look at
elephants for both body weight and uh
both both body weight and size uh and in
in in in and longevity of Life they get
cancer a fraction of what they quote
unquote should based on like cancer and
mutation curves of most mammals and it
is believed that a lot of that is due to
p-53 right um and it's just something
that's not as well studied as it
probably should be because most people
work in mice and then Pig so one of the
things that's interesting about what
we're doing with colossal outside the
the extinction or species preservation
uh efforts which I'd love to talk to at
some point if it's if it's it's an
option but uh but finding because we are
working in so many non-model organisms
we're starting to see really interesting
things and learning a lot about species
that there's just not been enough
Research into at least at the genetic
level and so I'm not saying that p-53 or
elephants have to cure to cancer but
they may and so we are working like for
us to do our editing think about that
for us for to create what's called
induced Flor potent stem cells the most
naive state of stem cells that then you
can reprogram into any type of tissue uh
which is very helpful for us right with
what we're trying to do um you know
we've achieved that in our marsupial
species the Fatal dunar that that that's
our model or for for thyine but in the
case of the mammoth uh and the Asian
elephants we're very very close we
haven't got there quite yet we we've
gotten to ipscs but we want to get to
further differentiation of them so that
we can really characterize them as is
the most purest form of ipsc is kind of
like a grading scale um and we've
achieved that kind of first step and now
we're kind of progressing but we
actually had to isolate and build a
construct around p-53 and learn how to
regulate it because think about what do
mutations look like they look like
cancer right and so when you're
introducing mutations into the genome it
looks like it looks like a form of
cancer so so we're learning a lot about
about you know how cellular regulation
works around p-53 which is really really
fascinating one of our advisers uh uh
Fritz volrath is is one of the top p-53
researchers has been very helpful to us
but um but fundamentally uh that's an
area where some of these species while
not massively reproductive viable as you
said as you as you so stated uh could be
really helpful if we understand more
about their genetics okay so dodo bird
symbolic
useful not being gone for that long
uh Tasmanian tiger would be good to stop
the Tasmanian devils from getting this
face
tumor also symbolic because they're only
extinct because in because the the
Australian government put a bounty on
their heads and paid people to eradicate
them so also very symbolic 100% man
cause the extinction or extin that all
of that being said woolly mammoths
functionally do some cool stuff what
cool stuff do they do how do they help
the planet yeah so so may so there
there's a group called Pine Park that
George has been working with uh for the
last 10 years in Northern Siberia and
what they found and they've done this I
think they published in eight different
peer-reviewed papers that if you can
build the if you can do two things if
you can remove these the the uh these
carniverous trees this tigga Forest uh
that is uh not the best carbon sink
they're also very dark bark uh they
almost like heat lightning rods that
have permeate that permeate that heat
down into the ground if you remove those
and if you get to the right level of of
cold tolerant dense uh uh cold tolerant
dense species the right level of density
you can actually lower ground
temperatures by up to eight degrees now
why and and I'll talk about that here in
a second but why is that important we
always talk about this 1.5 degree
Tipping Point well there's more carbon
and more methane and methane's about 30
times worse in the atmosphere that's
what kind of Venus's atmosphere is produ
really made of um there's more carbon
and more methane stored in the
permafrost in that in that Tundra area
than anywhere else in the planet it's
more than double what's been released in
the atmosphere it's over a trillion
metric tons of carbon in methane which
is which is terrible it's more than even
in the Amazon rainforest right because
the Amazon and the rainforest have a
carbon oxygen cycle that that just
repeats not in the Arctic it freeze
something dies freezes dies freezes and
just piles up right so there's this all
this condensed biom Mass there and you
know if it rele if it releases it could
be pretty bad I was actually with the
Army Corp of Engineers up there outside
of Fairbanks in the permafrost research
tunnels and it's just it's it's it's
absolutely amazing but also kind of
terrifying if it does melt and so what's
interesting is there's been studies
shown about how effective elephants are
specifically Forest elephants in Africa
at doing a couple things they actually
make the ground temperatures cooler
because they pack the ground and they
let the wind actually come down and and
hit the ground uh during the cooler
months so it actually makes the the
ground cooler number one number two
elephants love knocking down trees and I
know that sounds like but I thought
trees were good is do colossal have a
war on trees we do not have a war on
trees uh we just don't love the
non-efficient cornifer dark bark trees
in the Arctic that are not that aren
aren't helpful uh the the grasslands or
the Arctic grasslands of that time were
about two to three times more efficient
at what's called the alino effect at at
light reflection so anything that wasn't
absorbed for for those gr absorbed in
those gr grasses is not only uh is
reflected back to space about two to
three times more efficient than trees
and as well as they're about six times
more efficient at storing carbon down
into their root structures and so
there's been a lot of really great
modeling done that if you could return
the Arctic back to a more biodiverse
with these like Pline creatures uh uh
area where you have these natural
hurting animals during the winter
they'll pack the Snow Down Deeper or or
or pack the snow down so that the winter
months can actually like lower the
temperatures and we've seen that work in
Siberia already Mammoth like elephants
are natural they love knocking down
trees right so then you don't have to
use uh tractors and other uh equipment
like they're doing in Siberia to knock
down those trees and then just building
up that biodiversity in that area will
lead to a better oxygen nitrogen cycle
so that they will you know with their
defecation and what not they'll plant
more of the of the grass LS that are
more efficient in the summer months
right so so it's really interesting when
you put the whole puzzles together
outside of NIS it's about eight degrees
lower which is pretty important when
we're looking at probably surpassing
that 1.5 degrees that we talked about in
in the in the Paris agreement right it's
pretty important to keep all that that
trapped in and the the model is is that
Mammoth can be in a massive accelerant
and can push those numbers even higher
little hairy Farmers big hairy Farmers
walking all over the place so I I
volunteered when I went to Thailand
seven years ago I volunteered at a
Conservation Center that was reclaiming
land from monocrop monoculture stuff I
want to say soybeans maybe do they do
kind of agress it I anyway it was
somewhere that had been just one thing
and uh this guy had bought tons and tons
of hectares of land had also bought two
elephants he'd saved two elephants that
had been carrying mother and daughter
that had been carrying tourists up hills
one of those like classic like
mistreated animal stories and then
brought them in and I remember asking at
the time I was like why would like is
the is it just for fun or whatever and
they were like oh no the elephants they
keep the trees to a certain level they
help to rotate the crops and the
different ensure that manure from one
side goes to another side and then
there's fertilizer and they do all this
other stuff as well and uh yeah dude I I
realize that elephants are basically
Nature's farmers in a way yeah you're
you're 100% spot on and there was a
study that came out that we can get and
just send to you if you find it
interesting to read I think you probably
will where I I think that they defined
the in just Forest elephants in Africa
and Asia uh uh uh preserve the
equivalent of half a trillion dollars of
carbon credits that's amazing um and so
people breed more relevants breed more
relevants yeah and we want to we we we
want to do that right like that's part
of our
goals how do you have you considered I
know that you haven't got one
yet what is the game plan upon right we
can now produce Elephants or we can
produce mammoths at the pace of about
one every 22 months uh and then we can
like scale it yeah what do you do fly
them in fly them in on a on a big a big
like one of those C130 planes C130 yeah
no no um we work closely with the US
government but not I don't know if
they'll give us c130s for elepant
transports um so so the idea is uh kind
of twofold one let me talk about scaling
briefly and then we'll talk about reing
so on the scaling function you know uh
to your point breeding elephants is a
long tedious process right you're not
going to make thousands of Mammoth the
old fashioned way it's just going to
take a long time right but fundamentally
so we have a group and in and once again
what's so weird about my day-to-day life
today is is that de Extinction no longer
seems like science fiction to me because
I'm so close to it right it's like I see
where I see a lot more than the world
sees um and we try to talk about
everything we're doing as much as we can
um but I see I see how close some things
are and so how far other things are and
so D Extinction to me doesn't seem like
science fiction anymore uh the science
fiction part of my job is we have an
exor development or artificial womb team
uh that were really you know investing
heavily in and and I do think that
there's no major science Gates there
it's just engineering challenges right
you have to know enough about the
species you have to build the right
environment you have to en ensure that
you have the right placental interface
for the placenta um but but you could
really build out a exor development and
that's where you can get scale right and
this is before we talked about where do
you how do you put them back but you
know our long-term goal is to be able to
produce many many Mammoth and in you
know a facility right like where you're
not even using coget and and I think
that interestingly enough some of the
work that we're doing for conservation
is a GameChanger as we're building this
D Extinction toolkit but then separately
I think this artificial womb if we are
to be successful in it it will have more
an impact even than than all this other
work we're doing on species preservation
because if you could think about it if
you could grow you know we talk about
the northern white rhinos there's only
two left they're functionally extinct
because there's only two females but if
you could grow 100 Northern white rhinos
different engineered in genetic
diversity and then work with fre Wilding
teams to put them back into the wild we
need change conservation forever right
and so so I do think there's some things
that that we're working on that are more
science fiction uh but if we are
successful have kind of that scale
functions that you're talking about but
long term it's to actually have uh those
traing centers uh in the Arctic in
Alaska in our Allied nations in the
Arctic Circle and and actually you know
do that work there and then work to wild
there and you do that in heated bars
slap them slap them on the ass yeah send
them out into the world give them give
them a treat and and hope for the best
well you go can mammoths produced by you
are you just allowed to let them have
sex and and proliferate and then do you
get mammoths out the other side or does
something weird happen you do get
Mammoth out the other side and there
there's actually uh data to suggest that
Mammoth and Asian elep did interpr which
is interesting um but separate
conversation the um uh so we work very
closely with every nation every state
has slightly different rules we work
very closely with the US government
we're working with the Australian
government working with the Marian
government and uh and then we're working
with a couple of state governments the
US government's actually an investor in
one of the groups is an investor at
Colossal um and so for us uh you know
it's really important to be inclusive
not when we get Mammoth and slap them on
the butt and and hope for the best it
it's important to do it now right so we
spend a lot of time with the government
we spend a lot of time with different
Regulatory Agencies we spent a lot of
time with indigenous people groups
private land owners um and that's
important right because it's not just
about government regulation and support
like the EPA and and other equivalents
but you also have indigenous people
groups you have private land owners so
we've been we've taken the the uh stance
that the reing process is going to be as
long as the Engineering Process uh so
why don't we start that now and so just
because we we don't want approval we
want true collaboration and and so
that's that's one thing that I think
that we've done really right um we have
a team that that works with with these
governments and Indigenous people groups
and and holds Public Town Hall forums
that have conversations with local with
the local public both from an education
and a feedback perspective you know you
can you can actually learn a lot from a
Critic if you listen um and so I think I
think we've done a good job of taking a
wide range of feedback that we've been
given um you know more so on the
critical side less so on the please make
a dinosaur side
understood rolling the clock forward the
next question evidently is what does
this mean for humans does this mean that
we can change our DNA to survive space
flight can we give us the strength of
Neanderthals can we can we do do I know
you work with Chris Mason he had that
thought experiment in his book about if
you were able to make humans uh do photo
synthesis and you'd only need three
tennis fields worth of skin and you'd be
able to survive just on the sun like
some crazy butterfly of space yeah yeah
PL are the original solar
power um okay
so roll the clock forward for me what
can we do for humans so so I think so so
just to be transparent we are not
working in humans um we are working in
mammals I think a lot of the
technologies that we're developing have
applications uh to to humans in the case
that that occurs we spin that out as a
technology company we did that last year
with foreign bio our first aib based
computational biology platform but I
think as we get better at computational
biology and as we get better at editing
uh I think the sky is the limit right
and that's where you need to spend a lot
of time on the ethic side of it so um
you know uh I I do believe that from a
technology perspective you know it's not
possible or it's not allowed to do
germline editing so the editing that we
are doing in currently with with with
colossal you can't do that in humans
it's not allowed um but I do think that
as uh that changes because I think
that'll be a societal change over time
with more and more strict policies in
and not not probably strict but better
regulation around Gene editing because
right now it's like sounds scary we
shouldn't we should only do it these
limited cases but but it's incredible so
so let me give you let me give you a
real world example today and then I'll
tell you about tomorrow so uh they're
they're and I'm probably gonna screw it
up because I'm not a biologist but uh
they found that like I I you know I
don't know what your cholesterol is
right but um my my cholesterol is pretty
great but part of it is it's because
I've I've act I actually use a drug that
limit that that that stops and blocks
one of the genes my body called pks9 and
so what's interesting is is there's the
these pks9 Inhibitors um uh pcs9
Inhibitors that um that literally block
how your body produces LDL so some
people genetically even if you're vegan
do everything right th miles a day you
will produce too much LDL right it will
build up in your system and um this
lowers it by you know 40 to 70% it's
incredible and it's not I'm not I have
not edited my genome but I take a drug
that uh blocks that so what about a
world where we can edit out that Gene
where no one you know like like I I
believe that diabetes and heart disease
right now are 100% curable they they're
they're curable and I'm not just talking
about through lifestyle I'm talking
about through medications that exist to
day right and so from a human
perspective we are I I take a shot twice
a month in order to achieve that right
to to block that but fundamentally I do
believe that that that's something that
could be Gene edited at some point point
right and so I think in the near term
there will be applications of Gene
editing and Gene therapies that that
cure that I think in the long term I
don't think Chris Mason's wrong I I
think that we can become more radiation
tolerant and with more radiation
tolerant that people think about oh that
allows us to be a face a space fearing
species it also allows less breakdown of
our DNA and lets probably live longer on
Earth um and so um you know the sun is
not always our best best friend in that
right and so um so I do think that that
from you know I we already know about
genes like
myostatin myostatin if you've seen the
Belgian Blue cows you know uh we can
double muscle mass we can that's one
edit right it's one knockout like I'm
not saying you should do it uh some
bodybuilders May believe you should do
it but but uh but fundamentally to to to
your point you know I think that you
know uh we we live in a really
interesting time and you know from an
ethical framework perspective and a
regulation perspective I think that we
just have to be mindful of Ethics
regulation um but but I do think from a
technology perspective we are surpassing
uh uh the rate limits of of Regulation
and and and ethics in terms of what's
possible more is possible today than we
as humans are allowed to do yeah yeah I
had a a really interesting conversation
with Jonathan anomaly who is out out
here in Austin and he is about to
release at some point uh a company that
has been ready for a long time which
does uh embryo selection it does embryo
selection based on risk for all manner
of different things but it also can
select it can also select for IQ uh and
it doesn't select for IQ but it gives
you a risk profile where does where does
eugenic start and stop right not only
that not only not only that but with I
asked him this question I think it's
very interesting is what's the
difference between embryo selection
which you could do right now like you
just be like if you don't have the
actual samples you're like closing your
eyes and going uh IVF number five or
whatever right um what's the is there a
difference is there a fundamental
ethical difference between embryo
selection and genetic enhancement is
there and his argument is no I would
argue I would argue that the answer is
no because it people are like but we
can't create like GMOs or genetically
moded organisms are bad I'm like we've
been creating GMOs with crops for
thousands of years we've just been doing
it very inefficiently we've been
crossbreeding and crossing our
fingers right and like that we've been
doing that with dogs we have dogs that
are all different shapes and sizes that
aren't even very some of them are
genetically disposed to cancer because
we of the decisions that we have made
through selective breeding but selective
breeding is a form of genetic
engineering and so I would argue no it's
really not at its core and and so before
I don't know what exactly his Tech is
but another company I'm not affiliated
with but is called Orchid Health George
Church also co-founded it and they
actually you know in in when couples
have have a baby they'll get a they'll
get genetic testing to see if they're
compatible some people do compa some
tests you know for Down syndrome and
other stuff in womb right sometimes
people feel like that's controversial
but people do it and then um what's
interesting though now to your IVF point
is once you have those embryos to your
point you can crer you know close your
eyes and pick one but what's really
interesting is now they're doing a risk
score where they're saying this you know
this may be like the absolute best
looking uh Gene or best looking embryo
but you know we do full genome
sequencing on it now we can tell you
that you know it this has a
predisposition to late stage Alzheimer's
right so yeah do do even though even
though everything else about it it's
healthy do you w to insert that one or
do you want to take the gamble that and
we're gonna I mean this is this this
ultimately is the most interesting part
of what I learned from Jonathan um which
is at the moment what we do is we roll
the dice right we roll the dice with
whichever whichever is the fastest sperm
whichever is the egg that was timed at
the right time of the month or what
whatever whatever the right particular
month that is rolling and the it seems
like there are a number of defense
mechanisms I learned that um around
about 50% of all fertilized eggs are
cast out of woman's body without her
realizing within the first fortnite that
it's just you wouldn't you don't even
miss anything at all and there is you
know you you could imagine why that
would be adaptive that there's something
that's not gone quite right here perhaps
this is an early warning system that
just ejects this particular egg is that
a Mis is that a
miscarriage if you want aware of it kind
of and so they so I uh I I don't know if
this stats right but I I believe this is
in ballpark I uh I think George may have
told me this but uh natural birth is
about an 8% success rate which is kind
of crazy because there's so many of
these early stage uh ejections that you
don't even know about that that that or
that the woman does know that the female
doesn't know about and so it's really
interesting um you know because like
even IVF only gets you up to 5050 right
and so like you're it's crazy to me and
part of the reason why I think some of
those are only 50/50 is because they are
not doing full genome sequencing of the
embryo so you can have a a developing
embryo that that that looks great in in
microscope but it has a genetic defect
that at a certain point will not work
the body just says Nope yeah and so so
you so you're starting to your point it
takes like your if you have this many
the embryos you then go through a
freezing process you go through this it
keeps going down and down and down until
you do it but I think that what what
Jonathan's doing uh and what work at
Heth are doing are really really
important and you know but I also
believe that you know personalized
Healthcare everyone needs to take
responsibility for that they should get
full genome sequencing they should know
what's you know fundamentally not AC
body I I had mine done uh the other a
couple of months ago I got one copy of
the
c677t mutation not associated as a major
driver of Hine levels it's not as bad as
this other one blah blah blah just make
sure that you
supplement supplement with B vitamins
and some methylated some other
anyway I had that done I also went and
had a full body MRI brain angiogram
heart angiogram Dex
scan did you go to Fountain life Peter
dandis I no so Peter's a good friend
he's an advisor and investor in colossal
uh no I've done I've just done a lot of
that individually I I've even done a CT
uh cardiac angiogram scan which get you
which then uses this clearly analysis
this AI tool where they can tell more
think about this like few years ago they
were like still doing it's I think
people still do they do anagrams by
sticking like a Capal into your body and
going into your heart and looking at it
right like that all can be now done with
Imaging in AI so you can see like
pre-plaque buildup it's incredible and
so did you have the uh I I I got an
image of of the whatever the left
ventricle first first thing out they
were like oh we've got like not 5% or
whatever did you do the thing where they
uh IV you with that that makes your
torso go really really hot yeah yeah
yeah and it makes you feel like you're
gonna pee yeah dude that is the craziest
feeling yeah yeah that's the that that's
the contrast and makes you feel like it
makes me feel like I'm pee and so like
it was it's what it's what I imagine
being a dragon feels like oh oh yeah
100% I I know exactly the feeling but
but interestingly enough like this kind
of goes to I don't know what exactly the
results were but going back to like LDL
right they've now shown that if you can
get LDL down to 50 to 75 not only some
100 it doesn't continue to accumulate
but but 50 to 75 it actually reverses
and Dr Osborne uh in Dallas he's he's
incredible um he's one of the Pioneers
in this field and what what's what's
what's really crazy about it is you know
if you can start to not just like you
can stop and prevent any build up but
you can reverse any damage that's there
I mean you're not going to die of heart
attack or
stroke you that is a mitigable thing and
you may have to not just change
lifestyle you may have to take a a a
cocktail of drugs do it for the
rest of your life yeah but yeah it's
it's so it's interesting um I understand
why people get icky and I maybe would
have done if Jonathan I'll send you the
the episode you should check it out with
him I think you I'd love to yeah yeah he
he really just very
slowly walked me through step by step um
all of the different ways that we make
adjustments to ourselves and that we
have done to other animals we've done it
through selective breeding we've done it
to get rid of the Pips out of bananas
all sort of make them bigger and sweeter
and all this sort of and then
we do it to ourselves we modify
ourselves with I'm going to take this
antibiotic I'm going to take this
particular type of painkill I'm going to
take this particular Statin I'm going to
take this whatever he goes okay so let's
take this one step further you are a
person who has a predisposition to
anxiety or depression and you go go
through um embryo selection and we can
see on there we could maybe do some sort
of polygenic score and say it seems
based on our data based on the AI this
particular embryo would have a
predisposition toward uh depression
would it not like if you found as you
were the person that had lived your life
put your kids you're GNA put your kids
in the best school right so why not
start them off the best they can be
correct and then he said well you as a
person who has depression or
figuratively hyp hypothetically had
depression if you found out that your
parents had the opportunity to step in
and not give you depression either
through embryo selection which actually
technically would mean that you weren't
here so it kind of doesn't work but uh
we forget that bit uh or through uh Gene
enhancement and say what you you cursed
me with this thing and as soon as you
concede or let's say that it was
something really extreme right like you
you going to be born with like one foot
or like some sort of deformity or you
were going whatever whatever it's you
could have given me you could have taken
this away from me as soon as you con
seeed that that is a and I think he's
right a moral thing to do to allow that
to occur it's Off to the Races all the
way down to maximizing IQ like it's
the one of the things that that isn't
talked enough about is like you know you
know other countries have different
ethical views right like you know bgi
and China the Beijing genomics Institute
has said we're sequencing everyone we
can and we're trying to find the
smartest humans and we're going to use
it right and so assortative mating baby
just done by done by computer yeah and
so it's just it is one of those things
that you know uh you know there needs to
be more work in effort in thoughtful
regulation of these Technologies because
we can make the world better through
Gene editing like we we do that I'm
obviously I mean I I work at Colossal so
I do fundamentally believe that um but
you know I do think that that a deeper
lens on healthcare because I think that
we could we have the tools and
Technologies to make Humanity better um
today Ben lamb ladies and gentlemen Ben
I appreciate the hell out of you your
work's fascinating uh I'm glad that it's
not me having to turn up with this
pressure on my shoulders every day but I
think they've chosen the right guy for
the job where should people go they want
to keep up to date with all of
the Colossal
docomo that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe